>>> THEY WERE TURNED OVER TO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS BUT WE ARE JUST HEARING
ABOUT IT NOW WHICH MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE BACK THEN WE ARE ALL SO
FOCUSED ON THE START OF WOMEN'S
INDOOR TRACK SEASON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT ARE YOU LAUGHING AT?
> MO
RETURN THIS STUFF.
>> HOW THAT COULD POSSIBLY
HAPPEN? HOW CAN ANYONE BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE AND I THOUGHT WHAT
DATA THAT WAS IN THERE THAT
MAKES COMPROMISE SOURCE OF
METHODS AND BY THAT I MEAN NAMES
AND ETCETERA, IT IS JUST TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> POT OR WHATEVER. WHEN WE SEE
RAIDS ON BIDEN'S HOMES LIKE
TRUMP. WILL THEY GO INTO JOE
BIDEN'S UNDERWEAR DRAWER AND
DISCOVER THAT THEY ARE ALL MADE
OF IRON
OF IRON. MEANWH
FINALLY VISITED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER FOR THE FIRST TIME,
PERHAPS AFTER HEARING FROM HIS
WIFE ABOUT ALL THE FREE
BREAKFAST TACOS. AT A MIGRANT
CENTER, HE MET MEMBERS AT THE
SALVATION ARMY, IT SOUNDED LIKE
HE MIXED UP ONE OF THEM FOR
SECRET SERVICE. WATCH.
>> OH, SEEING THAT MAKES ME
THINK HE PUTS THE CEO OF OLD
NAVY IN CHARGE OF AFGHANISTAN.
>> OLD NAVY, IT GOT TO BE GOOD.
JOE WILL BUILDING A WALL AROUND
ONE THING, HIS DELAWARE BEACH
HOUSE. WHY IS THAT? WALLS WORK
AND THEY NEED TO KEEP OUT
HUNTER'S BABY MAMAS. SADLY, HE'S
NOT GETTING MEXICO TO PAY FOR
IT. TAXPAYERS WILL FLIP THE
$500,000 BILL OR ONE OF HIS
SON'S FINGER PATIEN
INTINGS C
THE JOKE.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY, JOE?
>> I KNOW THESE GUYS. I HAVE
RESPECT FOR ALL OUR MILITARY, I
DON'T CARE WHAT BRANCH YOU ARE
IN,
IN, RV
IN, R
s, RA
MACHINES.
>> I WAS AT THE FRONT LINE WITH
THE CIRQUE DU SOLEIL AND SOME OF
THOSE GUYS DIDN'T COME BACK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THEY'RE STILL OUT THERE ON
TRAPEZE -- DO, DO, DO, DOOO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WELL, WOW.
>> WELL-DONE. BASICALLY WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT DOCUMENTS. EVERYBODY
GOT DOCUMENT. TURNABOUT IS FAIR
PLAY. THEY MADE IT A BIG DEAL
UNDER TRUMP THAT IT WAS A HUGE
DEAL, WORST THAN WATERGATE OR HE
CAN GO TO JAIL FOR TREASON. THEY
KIND OF DESERVE IT.
>> I GUESS, ALL THOSE STORIES
CAME OUT BUT FOR TRUMP IS LIKE
HOW TO DO A BOMB. I DIDN'T KNOW
THERE WERE WORD DOCUMENTS
EXISTED? THERE COULD BE NOTHING.
I SAID THE SAME THING ABOUT THE
TRUMP STUFF. I REALLY DON'T
KNOW. I HAVE NOT SEEN THEM. THEY
WON'T LET ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHICH IS -- YEAH.
>> HAVE YOU CALLED THEM?
>> NO, THEY DON'T CALL ME. I AM
PLAYING HARD TO GET.
>> OH, THAT'S GOOD.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> I DON'T WANT THEM TO KNOW
THAT I WANT TO SEE THEM.
>> YEAH, NICE.
>> IT WORKED BEFORE.
>> IT HAS, IT HAS.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU ARE RIGHT
ABOUT THE WALL THING.
>> REALLY?
>> EVERYONE KEEPS ASSUMING IT IS
JUST A KEEP JOE SAFE FROM
INTRUDERS WHEN IT COULD BE
KEEPING JOE FROM WANDERING AWAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IT COULD BE HELPFUL.
>> IT IS TRUE, IT IS TRUE. A LOT
OF FREE WAYS THERE, YOU DON'T
WANT HIM TO GET OUT THE
INTERSTATE.
>> THE SAME THING OF FOR HIM
FORGETTING WHAT HE SAYS OR
MIXING UP WITH WORDS. USUALLY WE
HOLD PRESIDENTS ACCOUNTABLE
BASED ON WHAT THEY SAY BUT WITH
JOE, HE JUST SAYS STUFF AGAIN.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY. JOE SCREW UP?
WHICH ONE. TYRUS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THE WALL?
>> WE NEED TO PUT HIM IN A LIGHT
PRESERVER IN ORANGE JUST SO WE
KNOW WHERE HE'S GOING. YOU DID
DO JOE A FAVOR BY NOT SHOWING
THE REST OF THE VIDEO. WHEN HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE SECRET
SERVICE, HE HAD TO POINT TO THE
GUY OF THE SHIRT THAT SAYS
SALVATION ARMY, OH, SO YOU ARE
NOT SECRET SERVICE? WHAT ARE WE
DOING? HE GOT THE SALVATION ARMY
CONFUSED WITH THE SECRET
SERVICE. I NEVER THOUGHT I HEARD
MYSELF SAY THIS. KAMALA, YOU GOT
TO DO SOMETHING!
WHO'S MAKING THESE DECISIONS? HE
THINKS THE ICE CREAM MAN IS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. WHAT ARE WE
DOING?
[ APPLAUSE ]
RP
AN
AND FINALLY, WHE
BORDER, KAT, I AM SURPRISED YOU
DIDN'T TEAR THIS APART, THEY
MADE AN INSTAGRAM HORRIBLE
SELFIE OF THE BORDER, THEY
CLEANED IT UP WITH PICTURE AND
ALL HELL BROKE LOSE WHEN THEY
LEFT, LIKE YOU AND YOUR WIFE
SMILE FOR THE PICTURE.
>> EXCEPT WHEN HE DOES IT IT IS
LIKE THAT'S PROPAGANDA.
>> IT IS TRUE.
>> WHEN YOU THROW A PARTY WHEN
YOUR PARENTS ARE AWAY AND YOU
HAVE TO CLEAN UP.
>> YOU KNOW IN THAT PICTURE,
THEY ASK HIM, WHAT TIME THE
ELEPHANT WAKES UP AT THE ZOO?
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> KAMALA, DO SOMETHING!
>> EMILY, YOU KNOW THESE
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND BEFORE THE
ELECTIONS AND THEY COME OUT NOW.
IT SEEMS TO BE A PATTERN.
>> IT SEEMS TO BE A PATTERN,
YES. EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS AN ABSOLUTE
JOKE. THIS GUY, THAT WAS NOT A
VISIT TO THE BORDER, THAT WAS A
LAYOVER.
HE WAS ON HIS WAY TO MEXICO
CITY. THAT HAD MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS STREAMING ACROSS THE
POPULATION. HE CAN'T HANDLE THE
TRUTH. BEFORE HIM, BORDER PATROL
GETS TALKING POINT FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION. WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP WENT TO VISIT, OKAY, TELL
ME WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE. THIS
GUY FROM TOP TO BOTTOM LIVES IN
A MANUFACTURED WORLD AND HE DOES
NOT HAVE THE RESPECT OR THE
DIGNITY TO AFFORD THE OFFICE
HE'S OCCUPYING, THE RESPECT TO
READ GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S LETTER OR
MEET WITH BORDER PATROLS AND HE
CONFUSES -- THANK YOU THE SECRET
SERVICE? I AM MORTIFIED AND I AM
DISHEARTENED FOR THIS. THE MEDIA
COMES IN, OH, IT WAS A SMALL
AMOUNT AND RIGHT AWAY WE GAVE IT
TO THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES SO
EVERYTHING IS COOL. THE NUCLEAR
CODE IS ONE SENTENCE LONG. I AM
SICK AND TIRED OF HAVING THIS
PRESIDENT TREATING LIKE A KID
CLUB AND THE MEDIA EXPLAINING
EVERYTHING AWAY AND A SILENT
IMPOTEN
IMPOTENT VP ALSO
TWO YEARS OF THIS. IT IS GOING
FROM BAD TO WORSE, I DIDN'T
THINK WE COULD GET ANY ROCK
BOTTOM WITH THIS GUY IN CHARGE.
>> WOW, STRONG WORDS. JIM, YOU
ARE OBVIOUSLY, YOU ARE A
POLITICA
POLITICAL HISTORIAN. YOU ARE
WORKING ON "BIDEN'S TIME," I GO
TO
TWO AND PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
WHERE IS FOUR? I AM HISTORICAL.
THOSE PAPERS WERE HIS
HANDWRITTEN NOTE FROM THE
LOUISIANA PURCHASE.
>> REALLY?
>> I AM THE ONLY BIG PRO BIDEN
GUY HERE. I THINK HE'S TERRIFIC.
IT IS AN UNDERSTANDABLE MISTAKE.
THE SALVATION, IT IS S -- OR
SENILE.
>> HE TRIED TO PUT MONEY IN THE
GUY'S HOLSTER.
>> OH GOD.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THE WALL IS
FOR? BECAUSE HE WANTS TO HIDE OF
THE SUMMER HOUSE HE GETS. IT IS
NOT A NICE SUMMER HOUSE FOR
PRESIDENT. IT IS KIND OF
EMBARRASSING.
>> COMPARE TO OBAMA'S AND MARTHA
VINEYARD'S HOME. YOU SHOULD SEE
THE BAS
THE BASE
>> BIDEN LOOKS LIKE A SCREEN
SAVER WHENEVER HE WALKS.
>> HE'S JUST UP THERE UNTIL THE
WORK IS DONE AND HE GOES AWAY.
>> THAT'S BRILLIANT. I AM
STEALING THAT AND USING IT ON
THE